a South Korean city is attempting to
reverse its birth rate collapse with a
novel policy that I think we ought to
replicate here and that is to hold
public Mass blind dates to boost birth
rates this is the South Korean city of s
snam they held a mass blind dating event
at a hotel on Sunday for the express
purpose of getting young people to marry
and then have children because South
Korea's birth rates like so many birth
rates around the West are collapsing
according to one of the participating
men we are facing a real graphic crisis
and the government needs to do whatever
it can I don't understand people
complaining over this I I like the idea
that this this man participating you
know one of the blind daters just sits
down and he says hey baby hey baby how
do you like your wine do you recognize
that we have a collapsing birth rate
problem and the government demands that
we go back to my place and have a fun
night what that is a really novel pickup
line I never considered that one back in
my derel days but that's a pretty good
one